r.kelly remember you pissed on that girl
I still love you for that first video I
did really was right out of college and
I was just bored and didn't want to work
and so it was just like filming random
[ __ ] in my back yard
and I was like hey let's do a music
video this is what I didn't do parodies
to start I'm just like let's do a music
video
just like Lonely Island was really big
I'm like that's cool so we did this one
way back yard called look into my eyes
while I masturbate about these two dudes
in outer space left jerk-off cuz all the
girls got killed by kneeling and there's
some [ __ ] and that did good and I was
like woah cool back then if you got like
a hundred thousand hits to me that was
like 100 million so I was like I want to
keep doing this see what happens so I
did the first pair to ever did was boom
boom pow black eye peas and it was
called big old pubes we just gave her
some huge s bush we're dancing around
green screen did all backyard and that's
kind of how it came to be and then all
of a sudden it just ballooned and what I
do now the way I usually see what's
popular is I go to youtube.com slash
music and it's the top 10 music videos
right now so I try to I try to cover all
of those if I can some of them are like
foreign so it's not it's like I don't
want to do those that won't do
well but you know that's the best way
for me it's not about iTunes or
billboard it's just baby you gotta do
what's popular on YouTube if you get
enough attention on the on a video like
for example wrecking ball I did and and
now it's second related video to the
original which is like the biggest video
in the world so like it's crazy like the
amount of views you get from that
because it's the algorithm of the name
of similar people watch that and they
watch mine it's great so next week which
five-time misses up will probably be
maybe even around right now who knows
I'm filming a Lord Royals parody which
is you know that big ass when it worst
from New Zealand she came out of nowhere
16 years old song super popular video is
super boring and so I'm just like okay
we got to make friends chick so we're
doing that and then we're doing Miley
Cyrus 23 with Wiz Khalifa and juicy j oz
dude so I'm like she's rapping we have
to make fun of her I mean I make fun of
her so much but you know gotta do it I
think right now I really like the
blurred lines parody I did I think the
writing was really good and I liked the
ending because I've had five twists
instead of one and it was like all hell
broke loose and yeah man I really liked
that one and it was nice because I
wasn't a woman
it was Robin Thicke and yeah I liked
that one I also like Austin to Austin
Mahone one I did she's like a little bit
under the radar but I had a lot of fun
of that one too and it was I liked the
writing and that one the way it looked
there was a stupid dance so that one had
some good elements but I'd say blurred
lines right now that's my fave uh
there's a secret you know there's a big
difference between a parody and a satire
I think people don't get that because I
look at most parodies parodies on
YouTube they're not even making fun of
the original song or video which isn't
even legal so first of all if you want
to make a good Feherty you got to
actually make fun of the artists like go
for it people love that [ __ ] if you look
at the comments on any of these videos
it's mostly all negative stuff which is
funny so I can go
Commons we like oh that's funny I'll
actually take some people's ideas that
they're putting out there like oh this
and that and okay let's put that in the
lyrics somehow and then people feel like
oh I feel the same way so they really
like that and then another thing I like
to do is obviously the ending is always
like some something happens it's not
just like it's over there's some kind of
twist and I think people really like
that too it's just like out of nowhere
it's just a whole another element of
comedy that's been doing really well for
me they bronzed me with an airbrush it
took two hours they painted my whole
body basically I looked like one of
those bodybuilders he was just like way
too tan but you know what man like some
people are like don't do it like I'm
like it doesn't matter I'm not making
any comments about what color she is so
her frickin skin looks like that like if
I'm playing Carly Rae Jepsen she's pale
as hell I'll turn my say well I'll paint
my face biter so and you know at the
same time if people do get offended it's
good in the long run that'll get more
views it's starting to piss me off the
top if you look at all the top music
it's mostly girls especially right now
dude it's it's it's kind of annoying
like where the hell is Bieber's damn new
music video I mean he like Robin Thicke
he had his big one like he needs another
one and yeah I'm getting sick of it but
at the same time you know it's I like
doing it myself as opposed to hiring
someone else because I know exactly what
I want to look like an act and it saves
time in the long run because I can do
the performance I mean I recorded the
lyrics I can do the performance and I
won't forget the lines because I wrote
up that was the first like viral video I
did and she found it I'm prepared Korres
Hilton calm and she just tweeted me or
disturbing which it was it was a nine
year old man dressed as her so you know
and that that helped it out a shitload
obviously that was really cool that's
really the only time
the actual celebrity of making fun of
has tweeted it I think mostly because I
didn't really make fun of her that much
back then it was different now it's like
I don't think Drake's gonna tweet a
video where I'm literally calling him
out on everything unless I mean I think
it'd be cool if they did that I think
about it sometimes you know who I run
into Rebecca Black she was on a podcast
with Shane Dawson and she's like yeah I
saw this one parody this guy bar it was
so mean I really really don't like him
I'm like oh I like I mean she's young I
wasn't trying to be that mean it's just
like mostly making fun that dude who
makes the videos that creepy black dude
you know what I also been thinking it's
like cuz I was thinking like a little if
there's like an award ceremony at some
point like what would I say and I think
the first thing I say is I'm sorry to
everyone I know I'm not trying to be
mean it's just comedy it's just having
fun and honestly like I said a lot of
the stuff I'm right in is what other
people are thinking as well so I go off
I research these people like for a long
time to find out what other people are
writing other articles comments and then
I'm like put it all together
and most of these songs I'd like I'd
like the damn songs you know I mean I
have to I listen to him like a million
times in a row if I didn't like him I'd
probably shoot myself
so steve-o has been doing a bunch of
YouTube stuff recently and I've been
seen him around so I got his number and
he's like hey let's do something and I'm
like okay this is kind of this could
work for this video let's have him come
in and just rant do something steve-o
would do so you know you need a condom
and then I'm like will Miley Cyrus this
video is basically like a [ __ ] porno
let's get ron jeremy like how we're
gonna get ron jeremy i texted steve-o
steve-o who knows ron jeremy of course
so he just conference called like him in
I'm just like hey bro you want to be in
this video and he's like all right here
oh wow and he came and you know killed
it I've done a lot of really good
collabs and you know we do cretan
cross-promote and getting just getting
people in the videos who everyone knows
helps cuz everyone gets really excited I
go holy [ __ ] it's [ __ ] Shane Dawson
or it's [ __ ] Kingsley and they love
that [ __ ]
so I try to do it as much as I can I
think it still is I mean I mean look at
like some some of these some of the
biggest people now started recently like
maybe a year ago and some some of these
people just blew up
I still think you can do it it's hard it
depends on your format - you know I mean
I'm doing something that that not that
many people are doing and I'm doing it
you know I'm trying to be the best at it
so everyone knows this is the parity guy
right now let's you know this is why we
want to subscribe it's hard if you're
doing like vlogs and stuff
everyone's doing that you know I mean
even music just music in general it's
really hard if it's not comedic it's
hard videogames seem to be doing well
the game plan right now for me is just
putting out more content a regular basis
so I've been doing maybe one a month
because that's all I could personally do
is with writing and everything so now we
have a write like a writer who is
helping with stuff so it's like me and
him we can put our heads together and
obviously it's still gonna be the same
humor it's just somebody's helping so I
can literally write have to getting
written it once so that's why we're
filming to next week there's always that
dip when you take a break even if it's
you know two three week break when you
release a video it spikes like crazy
once you have a shitload of subscribers
everyone's liking and sharing it so the
more you can get those big videos on
it's just like it's gonna be crazy
and also the whole back catalogue of
these things like people don't stop
watching these like they show their
friends they send it to everyone so the
more videos you have like I could
probably not make a video for two months
and still be getting this close to the
same amount of views every day I'm from
Chicago originally like
and even there there's not much going on
I mean there's some people but you know
collabing and it's just not where it's
at this is this is literally the only
spot like this is where you have to be
if you want to get big fast come to LA
and you know do your thing you got to be
here you got to know the right people
you know I mean so you can get that
initial burst you can do collabs and you
know you do a collab with the right
person you could have ten subscribers
and you could get 50,000 overnight so
it's still possible yo guys thanks for
watching my interview if you want to
read the full interview and see my photo
shoot of super-sexy go to new media
rockstars calm also check out my channel
youtube.com slash Bart Baker if you want
to see some really messed up parodies in
a good way
until next time